[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: Before we
get on to the topic for today,
I felt like last Monday's
lecture was not my best.
I don't know why.
It's not that I
didn't put time on it.
I looked and I had the wrong
lecture numbers on slides.
There was all kind of chaos.
I'm sorry about that.
Sometimes you put
in a lot of effort,
and you still give a lecture
that isn't all that clear.
So let me try to tell you what
I thought were the main points.
I started off by saying why it's
really fundamentally important
to be able to understand
not just what people look
like from the outside, but what
we really care about people is
what's going on the inside
about their thoughts
and their beliefs.
And we are constantly
making inferences
about what people know, and
believe, and want, and think.
And we do that all
the time to understand
why they're doing
something and to predict
what they'll do next.
And so it's
fundamentally important.
It's the essence of being
a human being in many ways.
It's the essence of literature.
And we do it all the time.
And a classic way that people
have studied false beliefs is--
or thinking about other
people's thoughts is with
the false-belief task--
the Sally-Anne task
that I described.
And the reason people
use the false-belief task
rather than just a belief task
is if the beliefs are true,
you can answer what somebody
will do based on the world,
not based on their mind.
And so to unconfound the
two, we use a false belief
that's different than
the state of the world.
So we can be sure
we're asking people
what will happen next based
on what that person believes.
And through decades of use of
the Sally-Anne false-belief
task and variations
of it, it's clear
that there's a very
distinctive developmental time
course and ability to
solve this problem.
Five-year-olds
solve it no problem.
Three-year-olds
systematically fail.
And people with
autism typically get--
pass this task
late or not at all.
High-functioning
people with autism
pass the task, just
later, like 7, 8, 9 years,
not five years old.
OK?
So that's the kind of
behavioral background evidence
that there's something
distinctive about thinking
about other people's minds.
Then we considered
whether there's
special brain mechanisms.
And I argued that,
yes, there are.
There's a bunch of them.
But the most impressively
selective one
is the TBJ shown up there.
And the evidence that
it's specifically
involved in thinking about
other people's thoughts
comes from the fact
that that activation
is a greater activation
when you think about--
when you solve the
false-belief type problems,
when you think about
another person's thoughts
compared to when you think
about a representation,
a physical representation,
like a photograph or a map, OK?
So those are logically
isomorphic problems.
We have to always
answer a question
about a representation.
It's just the representation
is in somebody's head
or it's a physical
representation in the world.
And in that difference, you get
that region of the brain, OK?
So that's cool because it's
a very nicely designed--
it's not quite a--
nothing's a minimal pair,
but it's a minimal pair
in some respects, right?
It carves out whether
the representation
is mental or physical, but
it doesn't solve everything.
And a suite of other
tasks have shown
that that region is actually
specific in a whole bunch
of other respects.
It doesn't respond just whenever
you think about a person.
There are external properties.
And most impressively,
it does not even
respond when you think
about their visceral body
sensations, like thirst,
and hunger, and pain.
So the TBJ doesn't
respond to just thinking
about any mental states
of another person.
It's specifically thinking about
their thoughts and beliefs.
And that's pretty damn
remarkable, right?
It's, how abstract can you get?
And yet, here's a
specific brain region
for that very abstract,
very specific thing.
And the final little
bit of evidence I
showed you is that
it also generalizes.
It's not just about
language because you
can show people movies
that have no words in them
but that clearly show
characters who must be thinking
about each other's thoughts.
And in those moments when
the characters are thinking
about each other's
thoughts, that region
turns on, more, for example,
than when they're thinking
about each other's pain, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did somebody
look at what happens
if other people think about me?
Or if I think they
thinking about me?
NANCY KANWISHER:
You mean if you're
thinking about other
people thinking about you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, I would
assume that that region would
be engaged.
I'm sure there are
studies on that.
Because you're thinking
about their thoughts, right?
AUDIENCE: But more?
Is it more interesting?
NANCY KANWISHER: Probably
just because it's
more salient, right?
I actually, oddly,
in this class,
I talk about
attention at the end,
which is weird because attention
is an issue with every study.
But most of the brain
regions we've talked about,
surely, including this one,
are modulable by how strongly
you're attending to something.
So if something's really
salient, or important,
or you're really paying
a lot of attention to it,
you're going to get
more activation.
And if it's more
interesting to think
about what other
people think about me
than to think about what other
people think about each other,
you'll find some modulation
in here, I'm sure.
OK, and then finally, I
talked about moral reasoning
as a test case.
It's not that the
TPJ is selectively
involved in moral reasoning.
It's that many of the critical
aspects of moral reasoning
depend on what a person
knew at the time.
And so to use that information
in moral reasoning,
you need to pull that region in.
So I realized I wrote
that question ambiguously
on the quiz.
I meant to ask, is the TPJ
engaged specifically or only
in moral reasoning,
to which they answer--
the correct answer would be no.
But I didn't put
the "only" in there.
And I decided it was ambiguous,
so if you said "yes,"
you got the points.
Anyway, I gave several
bits of evidence that,
using the moral-reasoning
case, that the TPJ is--
it's stronger
evidence it's involved
in thinking about other
people's thoughts,
first, that we showed
that people with autism
will have this
difficulty in thinking
about each other's thoughts.
Even once they can pass
the false-belief task,
they put less emphasis, less
weight on what the person knew
at the time when evaluating the
moral status of their actions,
OK?
It's not that they
make a mistake
or that they're unable
to morally reason.
It's a pretty subtle thing.
It's just a small
difference in how much
they weigh what another
person knew at the time, OK?
That's also known as less
forgiveness or less exoneration
for accidental harm, right?
You kick somebody by
accident, and they go ouch,
well, maybe you get
a little bit of blame
because you were a
klutz and you should
have thought or something.
But it was an accident, so
you should be exonerated.
People with autism exonerate
slightly less, right?
OK.
So we then talked about
the fact that if you
zap the TBJ with TMS,
stick a coil there,
you do the same thing.
You slightly reduce
the weight people
put on what the person
knew at the time
in their moral evaluation
of the person's actions.
And then I showed
this bizarre fact
that, as I think
Gisella asked, well,
shouldn't the TBJ be different
in people with autism?
Yes, absolutely, according
to all of this, it should be.
But the basic univariate
measures-- how big it is,
how selective it
is, where it is--
do not find a difference
in that region
with that contrast in
high-functioning people
with autism.
That's surprising.
But one possible answer to
that is even though it's there
and it's just as big and
strong and all of that, it's--
that doesn't mean
it doesn't represent
different information.
And I showed you an example
that in typical people,
you can decode from the TPJ
whether the person is reading
about another person's
intentional harm or accidental
harm.
And you can't in
people with ASD.
OK?
So that's my summary
of last time.
And then all of that was
focusing very particularly
on the most fancy,
quintessentially human aspect
of social cognition, which is
this business of representing
each other's
thoughts and beliefs.
But I pointed out at the
end that there are also
lots and lots of other
facets of social perception
and social cognition,
many of which
have somewhat selective
brain regions, lots of them
other parts of the brain,
and we just didn't have time
to filtrate in to that, OK?
Hopefully that was a little bit
clearer than I was last time.
OK, so, so far, in
this course, we've
been focusing on all
these bits of brain
that seem to do very
distinctive, often
very selective things, OK?
So the one we've just
been talking about
is that little guy right there.
But we've talked about a
lot of these things in here.
And the field of
human-cognitive neuroscience
has invested lots of
effort to find these things
and try to characterize
what each of them does.
And that's pretty cool, right?
This is all stuff we didn't know
20 years ago, and it's nice,
and it counts as real
progress, I think.
But it leaves lots of
things woefully unanswered.
None of these regions
can act alone,
even though I've depicted them
in a somewhat silly fashion,
as nice little
M&Ms on the brain.
None of them act alone.
None of them could act alone.
They need information
to process,
so there has to be
input to each region.
They need to be able to tell
other regions what they figured
out or there's no point.
And probably, as
they solve a problem,
as they conduct
their computations,
they're probably
interacting all the time
with lots of other regions.
So we desperately need
to understand not just
that this patch does faces.
There's lots more
we need to know.
And one of the things
we really need to know
is, what is it connected to,
and who is it interacting with?
OK?
OK.
So that's what I just said.
And so that means
looking at not just
the cortex that
we've been focusing
on through this whole course,
this dark matter that's
on the surface of
the brain up there.
But today, we're going to
do a figure-ground flip
on the brain, and we're going
to start paying attention
to all that stuff that used
to be background down there,
all that white matter
underneath, which
is like a big heap
of myelinated fibers
that connect long-range regions
of the brain to each other, OK?
So you might say,
OK, just wires--
who cares about the wires?
That was my attitude
for a long time.
I've gotten over it.
We desperately need to
know about the wires
for all kinds of reasons.
So I'm going to go through
a whole bunch of reasons.
And there's a lot
of little details,
and I don't want you to panic.
I just want to give you the
gist of why this is worth
paying attention to.
OK, so first of
all, white matter
makes up 45% of the human brain.
So that alone tells you it's
not like some trivial thing.
It's a big part of your brain.
This is all the more
interesting because that's not
true in other animals.
So I think white matter
makes up a higher
percent of the human brain
than any other animal,
or at least we're way up there.
In mice, it's only 10%.
And maybe that's a relatively
uninteresting thing
about scaling with brain
size, but maybe it's
something deeper about
human brain-- what's
special about the human
brain and nobody knows.
And here's a fun fact.
If you took all the myelinated
fibers in the human brain
and you laid them
out end to end,
you could go around
the world three times.
So we've got lots of
cableage sitting in here.
OK.
So I briefly argued before that
you simply cannot understand
the cortex without understanding
its connections of one region
to another.
It's just crazy to study one
little patch of the brain
and not know who it's
talking to and where
it gets its inputs from.
And as I just said, the
pressing need for that knowledge
is heightened by the
presence of this map, which
we didn't use to have.
Now that we have this
map, it's all the more
important and pressing to
know what the connections
of those regions are.
OK.
So here's a nice quote
making this point.
This is Heidi Johansen-Berg
and Matt Rushworth.
They say, "Connectivity patterns
define functional networks.
The inputs to a brain region
determine the information
available to it, whereas its
outputs dictate the influence
that brain region can
can have on other areas.
Therefore, simply by knowing the
pattern of inputs and outputs
of a brain region, we can
begin to make inferences
about its likely
functional specialization."
So I think that's a nice quote.
It makes the point that
it's not just that we
need to know the connections,
but the connections
and the function are bound
to be deeply enmeshed.
One constrains the other.
Yeah?
OK.
Further, recall way
back, which will quite
possibly return on
the final exam--
how do we define
a cortical area?
I gave you criteria
for a cortical area.
And one of the criteria
was a distinctive pattern
of connectivity, right?
So it's part of the identifying
properties of a cortical area
is what it's connected to.
And so that's another
reason we should care.
A third reason is if we knew
of a given cortical area what
its long-range connections
were to lots of other regions,
that connectivity
fingerprint-- remember
we talked briefly about
connectivity fingerprints
a month or so ago?
That fingerprint,
the distinctive set
of connections of that region--
you can think of
it as a signature
of not just how
that region differs
from other regions in
that same individual brain
but how we might find a
homolog of that region
in another species.
And that would be a very
interesting thing to do.
Wouldn't it be cool to know,
is there a TPJ in macaques?
Well, macaques can't
solve an analog
of the theory-of-mind task.
Chimps-- we could
debate a little bit.
And narrow domains-- kind
of sort of, a little bit,
not really.
Macaques-- no, OK?
So is there a homolog?
Is there a corresponding
region that-- maybe we
took that region, and
we adapted it and made
it work better so we could
do better things with it?
And if so, what is it
doing in macaques, right?
I mean, I think that's just
a totally cool question.
And in principle,
one way to say what
counts as "the same region"
across species, which
is kind of a weird question.
They're different
species, so what
would "the same region" mean?
One way to say what
the same region means
is to have a similar
connectivity fingerprint, OK?
So there are several
studies that try to do that.
I couldn't cram them
into this lecture,
but if you're interested
in reading on it-- reading
about it, shoot me an email.
I'll send you some papers.
OK.
I also mentioned that the
specific set of connections
of a cortical region,
particularly its inputs,
play an important
role in development.
Remember the rewired ferrets?
If you redirect
the input to what
would have been primary
auditory cortex in a ferret
and you have that input
come in from the eyes,
you can get what would have
been primary auditory cortex
to become a lot like
primary visual cortex.
So connectivity is
important, not just
in how a region
functions and how
we say what counts is
the same across species
but is probably also
crucially important
in the development
of regions, OK?
I also showed you evidence that
the visual word-form area--
we can pick out
exactly where it's
going to land in
an individual brain
by the connectivity
fingerprint of that region
before kids learn to read,
further evidence that
connectivity determines
later function.
OK.
As if this is not
enough, other reasons
to care about white
matter is that disruptions
of white matter are at the root
of many clinical disorders--
dyslexia, autism, developmental
prosopagnosia, amusia,
all of these things and
others, for all of them,
disruptions in long-range
white-matter connections
have been implicated as possibly
playing an important role
in the etiology of that disease.
Aging-- most definitely
decline in white matter
is prominent in aging.
Sorry to say, there's a 10%
decrease in white-matter fibers
per decade starting at age 20.
Use yours now while
you have them.
Let's change the topic.
OK.
There's a lot of talk about how
white-matter connections may
change with experience, and
learning, and plasticity.
And that's a pretty
patchy literature.
And it's not a very
impressive literature.
The classic thing you
probably learned in 9.00,
that when you juggle, you
get changes in white-matter
connections from
juggling expertise.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
There's some problems with
a lot of that literature.
So it's an interesting
question, but it's not clear
what the strong answers are.
And finally, I don't know
about circuit design.
Probably some of you do.
But I gather that
people who think
a lot about circuit design--
one of the key features you
need to take into account
is wiring length.
You want to keep wiring
length short, right?
You have conduction delays.
You have heating.
You have space taken
up in circuits.
All of those things are
bad in circuit design,
and they're bad in
brain design too.
So a lot of reason to think that
a major factor in the design
of brains, especially
human brains,
is minimizing wiring length
because wiring length
is very expensive metabolically.
You've got to
maintain ion gradients
across cell membranes.
It's expensive developmentally.
These damn things need to
figure out where to go,
and if they don't go
to the right place,
you have a
developmental disorder.
And so it's probably
a real constraint
on designs of brains.
OK, so that was a
whirlwind-- lots
of reasons to care about
white matter and connectivity.
Oh, plus, at least
in animal research,
there's a whole suite
of amazing new methods
for looking at connectivity
in animal brains.
And [INAUDIBLE] can
tell us more about
that than I could
because she's working
in a lab that's right at
the forefront of developing
those methods.
Someday, we're going
to apply those methods
to a human brain--
I can't wait-- and get
the whole wiring diagram.
OK.
Anyway, so what do we know
about the connectivity
of these regions?
Well, you may be thinking, don't
we already know all this stuff?
After all, I showed you
this diagram way back.
And you've probably seen
it every damn course
you take in this department.
It's in most textbooks
in the field--
the whole wiring diagram
of the visual system.
So don't we already
know all this stuff?
So what's the big deal?
Well, here's the big deal.
That's a macaque brain.
And in macaque brain, you
can get the actual answer
to what is the actual
structural connectivity
of this patch of cortex
to that patch of cortex.
There's a whole
bunch of methods,
but traditionally, you
inject some dye here
that's uptaken by
neurons that travels
along axons that goes here.
You kill the animal,
slice up the brain,
and find that tracer over here.
And then those two things
are absolutely connected.
That's the gold standard.
And that's the basis of most
of those studies, that method
and variations thereof.
But we can't do that
in human brains.
And so we do not have
anything like this information
in human brains.
Yes, David.
AUDIENCE: When was this done?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
that is a compilation.
This was published,
in, I think, 1991.
But that was a compilation
of heaps of studies that
have been done before that.
It was a big review
article looking
at all of this literature, where
lots of classic neuroanatomy
people would do these
things where they
would inject tracers,
and slice up brains,
and look in other places.
And it was just a vast
amount of literature
that did that for many decades.
It's sort of fallen
out of favor,
even though these
things are, at least--
I don't know-- these are
really crucial questions.
Now people use other
methods to do that.
You can use all kinds of
optogenetic and other methods
to map connectivity in animals.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: In here?
Oh, that's a good question.
Oh, it's probably dorsal
and ventral pathways.
Let me see here.
Yeah.
Yeah, the red ones--
this is another thing I didn't
even really mention, probably
let alone give a
short [INAUDIBLE]..
That was lame.
But anyway, the visual-- high
levels of the visual system--
we focused on the
ventral visual pathway
coming down the bottom
of the temporal lobe.
But there's a whole
other visual pathway that
goes up into the parietal lobe.
Did I talk about that a little
bit-- reaching and grasping?
No, I didn't.
Lame, lame, lame, lame.
Anyway, a major part of
the field I didn't get to.
Anyway, it's a whole other
part of the visual system
that seems to be more involved
in visually guided action.
And they're actually
very interconnected,
but they're trying to emphasize
that the dorsal pathway is
at least somewhat
separable in monkeys.
But my point is this
is monkeys where
they have the
gold-standard methods,
and they can actually discover
the real connectivity.
Sadly, we can't do
those things in humans.
And in humans, we have only
three methods, and none of them
are very good.
So we'll talk about them
today anyway because this
is such an important
question, but the bottom line
is-- this drives
me out of my mind--
we basically don't know
the connectivity of any
of those regions for
sure in human brains.
And somebody's
got to solve that.
Maybe one of you will
go invent a method that
works in humans that helps us
solve that problem because it's
actually, I think, really
paralyzing to our field.
So I'll tell you what we
do know, which isn't much.
But, you know, beggars
can't be choosers.
OK, the first method has
been around for a few years,
and that's gross dissection.
And I mean gross, like
that kind of gross--
so only good for
post-mortem brains,
but it's really quite amazing.
This is a bottom view of
the brain back and front.
This is actually a
physically dissected brain.
Like, it takes a real
serious neuroanatomist
and lots of fancy methods--
I mean, not fancy
methods but lots
of careful, precise teasing
apart of bits of brain.
And you can actually see these
big fibers coming up here.
So if this is the
back of the brain
and we're looking
up like this, what
do you think those fibers
are connecting right there?
Big fiber bundle coming
from deep down in the brain
up to right in there.
AUDIENCE: Is that
thalamus to [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Bingo.
Exactly.
OK, so that's the
LGN right there.
And this is called
the optic radiation.
It's this huge cable
of fibers that come up.
OK, first, here's
the optic tract.
Actually, I forget.
That's not-- I think this
is the optic tract that's
been snipped there.
Then it comes up in here,
makes a stop in the LGN,
and then this big
batch of fibers
comes up right there to
primary visual cortex, OK?
Everybody got that?
OK, so you can actually see
it in dissecting a dead brain.
OK, that's pretty cool.
But what if we don't want
to wait for people to die?
Often, we want to ask
questions about a person right
now in their brain.
Do they have this disorder?
Are they at risk
of that disorder?
What is their connectivity?
So for that, we
have two methods,
and I'll talk about
these two methods
in the rest of the lecture.
The first one is
diffusion imaging.
OK, so I talked about
this briefly before.
But let me remind you of what
the basic principles are.
So here is a picture of the
optic nerve with a bunch
of axons oriented like that.
It's a big cable
with a whole bunch
of little fibers in there.
And the basic kind
of biophysics is
that water wants to diffuse more
along this length, following
the orientation of
the fibers, than it
wants to diffuse this way, OK?
And diffusion imaging-- I'm not
explaining any of the physics,
but just take it for my word
that what diffusion imaging
does is give you a picture
of the direction of water
diffusion, OK?
So you get a picture
of a piece of brain,
and it'll show you, for
example, that right in there,
all the fibers--
well, the water is
diffusing this way.
And over here, the water's
diffusing that way, OK?
And that's just what you see
in a diffusion image, OK?
And so the inference
people make is
if you have all those
parallel lines telling you
there's lots of
diffusion like this,
there's probably a big fiber
bundle going like that--
and there is.
That would be the
corpus callosum.
OK?
All right.
So this method works great for
finding the big fiber bundles.
OK?
I'm going to dis diffusion
imaging in a bunch of ways,
but it is great for
finding the big fiber
bundles because in
those big fiber bundles,
axons are very parallel.
There's a whole bunch of them,
and you can really see it.
OK.
And so people have
been using this
for over a decade to find
some of the major fiber
bundles in the brain.
So you may have heard of
the arcuate fasciculus that
basically connects language
regions in the temporal lobe
up to Broca's area in
the frontal lobe, OK?
It's a big bunch
of fibers that go--
I guess in me, they go
like this, boom, right?
[INAUDIBLE] And you can
see those guys with-- this
is a distant reconstruction,
but you can see
those with diffusion imaging.
Another one, the goes from the
front of the temporal lobe up
to the frontal lobe.
You don't need to
memorize these.
I don't care about that.
I just want you to get the
idea of what you can see.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So these are
discoverable without the person
having to do
anything [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
Yes.
These are anatomical images.
So in diffusion imaging,
you don't do anything.
You can sleep, actually.
That's ideal because
it's long and boring.
Actually, it's not
boring, but the scanner
shakes like hell in a
diffusion-imaging scan.
It's pretty wild.
We could charge
admission for it.
I don't know.
I find it quite wild.
Anyway, this is the inferior
longitudinal fasciculus.
As it goes down
the temporal lobe.
So when we talk about the
ventral-visual pathway--
face areas, place
areas, all that stuff--
this is the big fiber
highway that sits right
on top of that whole
chunk of gray matter
that does all the processing.
And it's a big pile of
fibers that go straight
down the temporal lobe, OK?
OK.
And so here's more recent data.
This is from Anastasia Yendiki
over at MHG Charlestown
over there.
And she's developed this
lovely piece of software
that enables you to take
diffusion images and identify,
based on an atlas
she's put together,
18 of the major fiber
tracts in the human brain--
so nine per hemisphere.
And this is just showing
you some of the big ones.
This is the inferior
longitudinal fasciculus
I just showed you and so forth.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how does
this compare to just
a postmortem dissection?
Could you see the--
NANCY KANWISHER:
It's a good question.
I don't exactly know.
It wouldn't be easy.
That thing I showed
you works because you
take the stuff off
the top, and it's just
kind of sitting there.
But then you would have taken
a lot of other stuff out,
and you wouldn't be able
to see that other stuff you
had to take out.
You know what I mean?
So here, you can surf through
and pick out any of these.
So it's definitely
going to be better.
But which of these you can
see with postmortem dissection
I'm not sure-- some of them,
some of the bigger ones
but probably not all of them.
OK, so here are some
of the major tracts.
OK.
But you can do a little bit
more than just find them
with diffusion imaging.
You can also characterize
them a little bit.
And this is a whole universe.
There's people who
spend their lives
with all kinds of
fancy measures,
and I'm just going to tell
you about the most common one.
So recall that the whole
deal with diffusion imaging
is it's looking for orientations
of maximum water diffusion.
So some parts of the brain
have a systematic set
of directions of
water diffusion,
and other ones don't, right?
Inside a ventricle, the
water can go any which way.
There's nothing determining
which way it goes.
So this is called
isotropic because you
have diffusion going equally--
in equal amounts in all
directions and anisotropic,
right?
So it goes systematically
more in one direction,
one axis than others, OK?
Diffusion can't see the axial
direction, like left or right
versus to left.
It can just see
that this axis is
more prominent than this one,
or this one, or this one, OK?
So you're not actually seeing it
move in a systematic direction.
OK, so that's the basic signal.
So what you can do is in
a little patch of brain,
you can ask not
just, what direction
has maximum diffusion,
which is what
I've been talking about so far.
You can say, how much more does
it go in that maximum direction
than any of the others?
Is it more like this
or more like that?
And you can imagine a
whole spectrum in-between.
OK, so you're just asking,
how oriented is it?
Is it totally oriented
or just partially?
And that measure is called
Fractional Anisotropy, or FA.
It's prominent enough in
the field you should just
learn this phrase.
And you read any
articles, especially
any clinical articles,
this is the first thing
you'll see in any
clinical papers that
use diffusion imaging.
OK, and so fractional
anisotropy-- there's
a bunch of fancy definitions.
And we don't care.
We just want the idea.
It's just, to what degree is
that little patch of brain
in this little part
of a tract that you've
identified more like this
or more like that, OK?
Is it anisotropic or isotropic?
OK?
And so this has been
used a lot to try
to ask about the nature of fiber
tracts in different groups--
young versus old,
different clinical groups,
autism versus typical,
schizophrenia, you name it.
Experience-- you train
people up on a task--
do you change the FA, the
Fractional Anisotropy,
of some particular tract.
OK?
So it's just a
characteristic of tract
is, how oriented is
it along the way?
Is it super clean,
totally oriented?
Or does it have some
isotropy mixed in?
OK?
All right, so this is
all over the literature.
Let me give you one cool
example from Gabrielli lab
that came out recently.
So they identified the arcuate
fasciculus that I showed you
before, going from the--
basically, Wernicke's
area curving around
up to Broca's area
up there so that you can
identify it anatomically
in each subject
individually, OK?
Now you've got it.
You've identified
which voxels are
part of the arcuate fasciculus.
And then what they want to ask--
what they wanted to ask
is, is the integrity,
or the characteristics of
the arcuate fasciculus--
is that important for
language-- for dyslexia?
So they measured the
FA along this tract.
How oriented is it all
the way along here?
And then you get
some kind of average.
And they measured that
in a bunch of kids
with dyslexia and in a bunch of
kids with no reading disability
who are matched in
other dimensions
of non-verbal
cognitive ability, OK?
And what they found is
the fractional anisotropy
was higher in the typical
kids than the kids
with reading disability,
with dyslexia, OK?
And from that, they implicated
that this connection
may play some role in dyslexia.
OK?
It's not totally
obvious because one
would think this region is
connected to that region--
those are languagey
regions, right?
It's not visual regions.
You think of dyslexia as a
problem seeing the letters
and which ones are
oriented which way.
And this suggests
that, at least,
higher-level connectivity
between language regions
may be implicated, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this just
talks about the architecture
and not the per unit
information being [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
AUDIENCE: There's no
information [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
It's just saying,
where are the wires,
and how organized are the wires?
Period.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So they won't
flow through some technique
as-- if I can mess
with it, like I'm
measuring it, if
there's some means
to miss the
[INAUDIBLE] diffusion,
will that have any effect?
NANCY KANWISHER: I
didn't quite get that.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: So there's
this water diffusion
that's happening that
I'm going to measure.
But what if I have some
way to intervene and change
the rate of diffusion some such?
NANCY KANWISHER: I don't
know how you'd do that.
I mean, it's a pretty
basic physical property--
diffusion of water and how it's
constrained by lipids, right?
AUDIENCE: But that
shouldn't affect,
like the function of
information flow [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Ooh.
I have no idea.
I mean, that's a biophysical
question I don't know about.
But notice, this is a
pretty distant proxy.
You're mostly looking at
water between axons, not even
within them.
And so it's just a proxy
for, how well can we
see those fibers and how
they're oriented, OK?
Yeah, it's pretty removed
from actual signals
going along the wires.
Anyway, so everybody get
the sense that-- you know,
it's one little finding.
But it implicates something
about that tract in dyslexia.
OK, so that's interesting.
But first, it's
just correlational.
Lots of things are
Most of the stuff in this
class is just correlational.
Same is true here.
But a little more
seriously, it's
not totally clear what
fractional anisotropy means,
OK?
So there's a real
tradition of treating
high-fractional anisotropy
as if that's good.
After all, we're
in a fiber bundle.
Shouldn't all the axons
be oriented nicely
in there and not all scrambled?
Surely, oriented is good,
and scrambled is bad.
Well, maybe, but sometimes,
fibers cross a fiber bundle.
So you can have a fiber bundle
like this with other fibers
crossing it.
And so when that happens,
maybe that's good.
And so people use FA as
a proxy for good fiber.
People say "fiber
integrity" even.
But there's a whole question
about what exactly it means.
People will spend
their lives looking
at the biophysics of fibers
and all the different things
that fractional anisotropy and
the other measures might mean.
And it's actually pretty
complicated and unresolved.
Another challenge with
fractional anisotropy
is it's extremely
vulnerable to artifacts.
All of diffusion
imaging is extremely
vulnerable to artifacts, OK?
And I'm going to give you
an example of a study we
did a few years ago.
So I was, for a while,
trying to work on autism.
I've, more or less,
given up because it's, as
far as I can tell, impossible.
But back while I
was still trying,
we scanned a whole bunch of
kids with and without autism
with diffusion imaging, OK?
And at the time, there were
about 50 published papers,
almost all of which said one of
the things you find with autism
is that there's an
underdevelopment
of long-range connectivity
and an overdevelopment
of short-range connectivity.
And so then people
would free associate
with all kinds of
speculations about,
OK, this explains aspects
of the autism phenotype.
They can't put
different ideas together
because their connections
across the brain aren't as good.
And they're obsessed
with little details
because they have too many local
connections and all kinds of--
suggestive, but very, very
fuzzy ideas like that.
So 50 papers pretty much all
found underdeveloped lower
fractional anisotropy and
long-range connections,
long-range tracts in autism,
a very established finding
So we went in not to
raise hell but just
to kind of replicate
some of those
basic findings while
studying some other things.
And, in fact, when we did
what everyone else does--
that is standard analysis--
you collect your
diffusion-imaging data,
and you eyeball it
loosely, and if it really
looks terribly
tainted with artifact,
you throw that subject out.
And, otherwise, you keep it,
and you analyze your data.
And you look at, here
are the 18 fiber tracts
that I showed you before.
And you ask, which of
those have higher or lower
fractional anisotropy
in kids with autism
compared to typical kids?
And the basic finding--
we replicated the usual finding.
And that is, overall--
this is column A--
most of those tracts
showed lower
fractional anisotropy
in the kids with autism
than the typical kids, OK?
Many of those differences
were individually
significant in
individual tracts.
Those are the ones
with the asterisks.
OK.
So that's the standard
finding in the literature,
and we replicated it.
However, we noticed
that a lot of the data
really seemed suspect.
And we started
measuring the amount
of head motion between the
kids with autism and the kids
without.
And guess what.
Kids with autism move in the
scanner more than kids without.
And guess what.
Diffusion imaging and fractional
anisotropy in particular
are highly influenced
by head motion.
So then we said, OK, let's
get a little more careful.
And so we did a more
stringent analysis.
And we looked at the kids.
We had quite a few of
them in each group.
And we took the subset
of kids who we could
match for head motion, OK?
So now we've got the kids with
autism and the typical kids,
but we've now got the
subset we have to choose
to match for head motion, OK?
It usually means the typical
kids who move a little more
and the autistic kids who had
slightly less head motion.
That's what you need
to do to match them.
And when we do that, the
usual pattern disappears.
Now there's only a
single tract that
shows lower
fractional anisotropy
in the kids with autism
than the typical kids, OK?
The inferior
longitudinal fasciculus.
So that's worrying.
But then further, we thought,
OK since many of those kids
we had, especially the
typical kids-- many of them
we had scanned twice.
So we thought, OK, let's
really make this case.
This is clearly a
problem in the field.
In fact, it's a broader problem.
Pretty much any comparison
across age groups
or clinical groups--
one group moves more
than the other group.
Uh-oh.
What about the
entire literature?
Hundreds, probably thousands
of published papers,
essentially, none of which
pay attention to this--
this is 2014.
People have cleaned up their
act since, but up until 2014,
almost none of them
paid any attention
to this whopping problem.
So we figured we better
make this point salient
because there's a
lot of money and time
being wasted publishing garbage.
And we want to make
the point saliently.
So we took the typical kids
who we had scanned twice, OK?
And sometimes a kid
will-- the same kid
will move more in one
session than another session.
So we said, OK, let's
compare the very same kids
on the session where they
move more than the session
where they moved less.
And you know what?
We replicated the
autism phenotype.
Those were typical
kids, not autistic kids.
The point is head
motion alone will
reduce fractional anisotropy
and will look a whole lot
like a clinical disorder.
And so every time you see that
a clinical disorder is marked
by some anatomical difference,
your first thought should be,
how carefully did
they deal with head
motion and other
artifacts that are
going to differ between groups?
OK?
So I say that not to dis
the entire literature
but just to alert you that
these things can really matter.
The paper from Gabrielli
Lab that I just described--
I looked, of course, before
I presented it in here,
and they cited us, and
they used our methods
for matching head motion--
good for them.
So these things
are changing, and I
think the field will
start cleaning up its act.
But it's amazing
it took this long.
OK.
All right, so
finding fiber tracts
and characterizing them
with fractional anisotropy
are nice, but, really,
what we want to know
is what's connected to what, OK?
Which of these things are
connected to each other?
Which other brain regions
are they connected to?
And so to find that out,
we need to not just study
white matter itself
and the tracts,
but we have to get
out of the tracts
and into the gray matter.
So we need to start in
a patch of gray matter
and figure out where we can go
by following those axons, OK?
And so the method for doing
that is called tractography.
So there are many
versions of this.
I showed briefly
these pictures before.
I'm sure you've seen these.
The simplest idea
of what you do,
leaving out all
the details, is you
start in some
gray-matter region,
some voxel in the gray matter.
You want to know what
it's connected to.
You just follow those little
orientations, and you can--
you see where you can go.
OK?
And so that's basically
how you make this diagram.
OK?
You're just following those.
You start over here you follow
the orientation-- go do, do,
do, do, do, do, do, right?
OK?
I mean, you do that
in a computer, right?
An algorithm does that,
follows along-- ch, ch, OK?
OK, so that's
called tractography.
And the idea's
awesome-- how great
to be able to see what's
connected to what.
And there are many,
many thousands
of papers that do
this for good reason.
We need to know what's
connected to what.
This is our
currently best method
for looking at the
structural connectivity
of different gray-matter
regions to each other.
And so you can ask,
for example, OK,
let's put a seed in
the fusiform face area
and see where it goes.
Wouldn't that be cool?
Right.
Wouldn't it be cool?
Unfortunately, it doesn't work.
So I have to tell
you that I don't
know if I'm the best person
to report to this because I'm
not--
I've only been trying to
do this for a few years.
But, I've been collaborating
with the best people
in the world over there
at MGH Charlestown who
are working closely with us.
And we can't get this
thing to work worth a damn.
And so now I'm actually confused
whether the entire literature
is garbage.
I don't think it's
entirely garbage.
But I think it's full of
overoptimistic evaluations
of what you can tell
from tractography
because in our hands, we
started with reality checks,
put a seed in the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
Let's make damn sure
we can get up to V1.
Well, you can get
up to V1, but you
can get up to V2,
and V3, and V4,
as well, which are
all wrong, right?
LGN only goes to V1.
Worse, you stick a seed next
door in the medial geniculate
nucleus, which is the part
of the thalamus that goes up
to auditory cortex,
you also end up in V1.
Wrong.
There's not very many anatomical
connections in the human brain
where we actually know
the right answer where
we can do these reality
checks, but of the ones
we know that we've
tried, it doesn't work.
And we're using the best
diffusion-imaging scanner
in the world.
It's right over there.
So maybe I'm doing
everything wrong.
But at the very
least, I think there
are a lot of problems
with this method.
This is not just me
worrying about this.
And many people
have been worrying
about this for the whole 15,
20-year life of diffusion
tractography.
And some of the challenges
are, like, famous.
So to follow those
little orientations,
you need to-- you can see,
like there'd be lots of places
where, OK, there's a bunch of
different ways you could go.
It's ill posed, right?
So people use heuristics to
constrain those solutions.
And those heuristics
are based on assumptions
about how fibers bend
in the brain, namely
that they don't make
really sharp angles, right?
That's reasonable.
Most of the time they don't,
but sometimes they do.
And in particular, when
you're going from white matter
to cortex, often, you
make a very sharp turn.
And so it's very, very
difficult to figure out
how to get from a
given gray-matter patch
into the underlying
white matter exactly what
the connectivity is.
So that's one problem.
Another famous problem
with tractography
is called the
crossing-fiber problem.
So imagine a bunch of axons
somewhere in the brain
that cross like this versus
imagine a bunch of fibers
in the brain that come up to
each other and then go apart,
OK?
Everybody get this?
The connectivity's
totally different here--
no way you're ever going
to distinguish those
with diffusion tractography.
So people try to get higher
and higher resolution
to see down those individual
things, but they're not there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why would
something like that happen?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
why would they do that?
Weird stuff happens
in the brain.
So it's not incredibly common,
but it's not unheard of.
Yeah, remember, the
brain wasn't dissolved--
designed now optimally
to solve all the problems
it needs to solve with the
optimal solution from scratch.
It evolved gradually over time.
And so there are all
kinds of weird things
that are workarounds for
pre-existing decisions
that evolution made earlier.
And so both brain and body
have lots of bizarre attributes
that aren't how you would
design it from scratch.
They're just the fix that
evolution made at that point
given what had
already been fixed.
And so there's weird
stuff like that.
Anyway, I mention
this to say I'm
more negative about diffusion
tractography than probably
anyone else because I've spent
a lot of the last two years
trying to do it, and it's
big bust, and I'm cranky.
So it's probably not as
bad as I'm laying out.
Plenty of people do it.
They get some kind
of answers out of it,
but it's problematic at least.
My best guess is that it
is OK for fingerprints.
If you're asking, OK,
here's some patch of brain.
How much does it connect to,
say, these 85 other regions?
And is that different than the
fingerprint for this region?
That's probably OK because a lot
of those individual solutions
might be wrong, and there's
still enough left over
to see a kind of difference.
So I feel like you can--
conductivity fingerprints
are probably worth doing.
But, actually, just
answering the question of,
is there a structural
connection from A to B--
I don't know.
I can't get it to work.
OK?
OK, so I think I did all
this before just to--
conductivity fingerprints--
do you remember this?
You start with
one place, and you
measure how well you can
get from each location
to each of these other ones.
And I showed you
before that the work
of Zeynep Saygin and a
bunch of other people
has shown that you can--
actually, in an adult,
you can predict where
that adult's fusiform face
area is just from their
diffusion tractography data
alone because it has a
distinctive connectivity
fingerprint, OK?
I don't want to go
through all that again.
Do you guys remember that,
more or less, the gist?
OK, so that just
tells you that there
is this systematic mapping
between the connectivity
of a region and its function.
And connectivity fingerprints,
despite all these problems
I've been carrying on
about, have enough signal
left in there to predict
the function of a region
and maybe to say something
about homologies across species.
OK, blah, blah, blah.
Right.
OK.
So where do we get?
You can find the major fiber
bundles with diffusion imaging.
That's worthwhile.
You can characterize
fractional anisotropy.
I don't really know what it
means, but it means something.
And you can find very
approximate connectivity
fingerprints good enough
the predict function.
OK, so that's worthwhile.
But actual structural
connections of one
particular cortical area--
not very good.
At best, it's a weak signal.
So that's a drag.
So let's consider
the other method
people have used to try
to work these things out.
And that's resting
functional correlations.
So let me describe
where this story starts.
This story starts with a
paper in 1995 by Biswal,
and this is the
figure from his paper.
So, first he had people move--
they had-- he had people in the
scanner doing finger-tapping.
So they're lying in the scanner.
He's scanning their brains while
they tap both fingers or not,
or tap both fingers or not.
And you get these-- it's
hard to see-- these two
little bits of motor
cortex corresponding
to the finger-motor region.
OK, no surprise there.
We're just mapping a
little bit of motor cortex.
But then he does something cool.
He looks at the time
course over that experiment
in one of those motor regions--
in one hemisphere, and he
looks at the time course
in the other hemisphere when
the subject is at rest, not
doing anything, OK?
Sorry, I left this out.
You scan them doing
this, and then
you scan them just lying there
going, dum-de dum-de dum,
or whatever you do when
you don't have a task, OK?
And he finds that these very
far-apart regions at rest,
when the subject is not
tapping their fingers,
are extremely correlated.
So that's very not obvious.
These things are
centimeters apart.
The subject isn't doing
anything in particular.
You're not telling
them what to do.
And they certainly aren't
tapping their fingers.
So why are these two bits of
finger-motor cortex going up
and down in lockstep like that?
Well, nobody knows, actually.
I mean, this was however--
20-some years ago, right?
Still, nobody really knows why
those damn things are going up
in lockstep like that.
But it's systematic,
it's tantalizing,
it makes you want to play
more, and many people have.
OK, so I would
say we still don't
know exactly why those things
are going up and down together.
But the pattern of brain regions
that go up and down together
has proven to be a
whole fascinating window
into the brain.
OK, so that's our
next topic here.
OK, so here's another depiction
of more exactly what you do.
OK, so step 1--
you find a seed region in here,
in left somatosensory motor
cortex, OK?
So that's that region there.
You get its time course, OK?
Sorry, at rest.
You find that region, and
then you scan the person
while they're just told to
do nothing in particular.
You get the time course averaged
over all those voxels at rest.
There it is, OK?
Now you take that time course.
And you correlate it
with the time course
of every other
voxel in the brain.
And you say, show
me all the voxels
that are correlated with
this region at rest.
And you get this--
lots of systematic
brain regions that
are highly correlated
at rest with that region
you started with.
Everybody get what we just did?
OK, totally non obvious.
Well, you might say, OK, fine.
This is finger-motor cortex.
This is the other one.
That's what I showed
you from Biswal before.
But why this thing?
Why this thing way
down deep in the brain?
Why that thing down in
the cerebellum miles
away in the brain?
Why are they all in
cahoots with each other.
I like using "in cahoots" when
talking about correlations
because nobody knows what
the correlations mean.
So "in cahoots" is as technical
as I think we should get.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: --correlations
without a time shift.
Just [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
Good question.
Wouldn't we love to know
about the time shift?
But here's the problem.
There should be a time shift
because it takes a while
to conduct down axons from
here to here, probably
a few milliseconds.
But a few milliseconds
we are never going
to see with functional MRI.
So, surely, there
is a time shift,
but this method
can't exploit it, OK?
Yeah, I'll just
leave it at that.
OK, but does everybody
get what this map is?
We've just chosen a
seed region, a starting
point just for the hell of it.
And we've asked, what
other bits of the brain
are correlated with
that region at rest?
It's a pretty weird thing to do.
And you wouldn't do it if you
didn't find systematically
replicable answers that are
repeatable across subjects.
And when that
happens, you go, OK, I
don't know what this means,
but it's pretty systematic.
Let's keep following the thread.
OK?
Question?
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
by correlated [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
so let's do this again.
You scan people
moving their fingers.
You find little-finger
region here.
Now you scan the same
person just in the scanner.
You say, I'm going to
scan you for five minutes.
Just close your eyes and don't
do anything in particular.
You lie there.
I scan your brain.
Now I take that region,
which I found before.
And I take the time
course of that region
while you were just lying in
the scanner doing nothing,
and I get some randomish-looking
thing like this.
Now I take that time
course, and I say,
let's see if there are any
other voxels in your brain
that were correlated when you
were lying there with that time
course.
And I color them in, and
there are lots of them,
even regions that are far away.
OK?
It's really not obvious.
You wouldn't have predicted
this would happen, yeah?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if you look
at the brain just as
some underlying resting rhythm
and like just all regions
of the brain just have
some resting rhythm,
wouldn't it be just
always be [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
OK, so there's been a
whole suite of speculations
of exactly that kind.
Are there endogenous
rhythms that
are characteristic of
particular brain regions
and so those things go together?
Maybe, but so far, that doesn't
seem to be the main answer.
For a long time,
people thought, OK,
is it just blood-flow supply?
Maybe the blood-flow supply
to the brain branches
and feeds those regions,
and that somehow
regulates the bold
response in those regions.
There have been many accounts
like this, and none of those
seem to really capture it.
It really seems like, probably,
those neurons are firing
in sync with each other, right?
Yeah, question, Nava?
AUDIENCE: Yes, before a
question in direction--
if you have a time
delay, I guess
the question was because if
you would have a time delay,
you could see what's
further right.
Can you, instead
of the time delay,
see if you measure it in one of
the regions that seems to be--
seems to be correlated-- if
you measure from one of those,
if you could estimate the
distance based on how strongly
they correlate [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
with the thought of maybe
there's not a time
delay, but maybe you
lose some of your
correlation with distance.
You could.
But just looking at this, these
guys are pretty far apart.
So it's certainly not that
there's just things are--
that nearby things
have a similar.
AUDIENCE: No, but I
mean, if you would
say those are five
different regions,
did you measure from region 1?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, yeah, I got you.
Yeah.
Yeah, you could.
I think that's not going
to work because there
are big, big correlations
that people find
between very distant regions.
I'll show you more.
Yeah.
I mean, you could try that, and
I'm sure people have done that.
I can't tell you exactly where.
Actually, they do it as part of
their-- one of the common ways
you normalize your data is
to take this and normalize it
for distance from the seed
region, which would be a way
to build that factor in.
And once you do that, you
still get lots of stuff.
AUDIENCE: They take the
distance and the image space
for that, right?
NANCY KANWISHER: You can
do it different ways.
There's an algorithm
that somebody at MGH
wrote that is distanced by,
most likely, a white-matter path
or as the crow flies, not
that the crow can fly straight
through the brain, but
you see what I mean.
Yeah.
Sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is the
result different
in if you measure
the correlation when
they're doing the finger-tapping
action versus [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
OK, so this is a really
important question,
and it's a whole
part of this field
that I'm leaving
out of this lecture
because I'm sort of
suspicious of it.
But your question is a good one.
So you're saying, would
they be correlated
while you're finger-tapping?
Well, certainly, if
we did the paradigm
while they're
tapping both fingers,
they're going to be
correlated because we built
the correlation into the task.
We said, while you're
doing this, do that.
And so they will
surely be correlated.
And so there's a
whole enterprise
where people try to factor
out those things and ask,
even after you account for
the activation of the task,
are there changes in these
patterns of correlation
with the task you're doing?
And that's called PPI for
physiological interactions.
And lots and lots
of people do it--
hundreds, thousands of papers.
It's probably
pretty respectable,
but it drives me nuts because
I don't feel like there's
any way you could
know that you're fully
accounting for the task.
And so I think those
correlations may
be largely reflecting regions
commonly activated by the task,
and that's why I didn't
put that in this lecture.
But surely, task will also
produce correlations, right?
Let me just put it another way.
If I flash up a bunch
of faces versus--
it's like faces versus nothing--
and then we look
at the correlations
during that period, well,
you'll find correlations
between V1 and the FFA
because when their face is on,
both V1 and the FFA turn on.
And when there aren't,
they both turn off.
That's just a task
response, right?
So to be able to look at how
these endogenous correlations
are affected by
task, we would have
to be certain we could siphon
off the entire task effect
so that we could look
at just the residual.
And I don't think
any of our analysis
are good enough to siphon
off an entire task effect.
And that's why I just
don't go there with PPI,
even though everyone else does.
If you didn't follow
that, it doesn't matter.
I'm just trying to
give you an answer.
I'm going to take just
questions of clarification
now because there's a couple of
things I really want to get to
and I'm running out of time.
OK.
But everybody should
understand this--
an activation map that's made by
asking, which brain regions are
correlated at rest with a given
region I choose a seed region
I choose?
OK.
OK, important caveat--
even though people
call this "resting
functional connectivity,"
we will not be using
that phrase in this class
because we do not know
that it's connectivity
in the structural sense.
It's just a correlation, OK?
And I'll say more
about that later.
But if you read about resting
functional connectivity,
it's the same thing.
It's just, I think, people
are making a mistake
using that word.
OK, so let me get
this idea across here.
You may have heard of
the default-mode network.
There's heaps of papers on this.
It's a thing.
There's a lot of
discussion of it.
And it's bizarre.
It has arisen from two
independent findings,
OK?
So let's do these
findings one at a time.
The first one is people started
noticing around 15 years
ago that across lots of
different kinds of tasks,
if you looked at not the
intended direction, like, say,
reading sentences
versus staring at a dot,
or doing a demanding
working-memory task
versus a really passive-viewing
task, anything where there's
a really engaging task
versus an easy task,
you would find a
bunch of regions
that were activated in the
reverse contrast, regions that
are more activated when you're
doing less mental activity,
typically, regions that
are active when you're just
lying there at rest compared
to doing something difficult.
And so originally, people were
like, what's up with that?
How can that be?
It seemed paradoxical,
impossible.
But, in fact, it's
not impossible, right?
Suppose I had you do a bunch
of mental-arithmetic tasks,
and they're pretty demanding.
And I compared that to
just having you lie there
in the scanner doing nothing.
It's like, OK, do mental
arithmetic for 20 seconds, rest
20 seconds, mental
arithmetic for 20 seconds,
rest for 20 seconds.
Now imagine we find parts of
your brain, systematic ones,
that are more engaged at rest.
What might that mean?
David.
AUDIENCE: That part of the
brain could be, I think,
like daydreaming.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Daydreaming, exactly.
Yeah.
You can't turn your brain off.
You don't turn your
brain off at rest.
You daydream.
Absolutely.
What else?
What are the things--
some of the things
you do when you daydream?
What are the typical
contents of daydreaming?
I guess it depends who it is and
what you're daydreaming about,
but there are very
systematic things people do.
They recall episodic memories.
It's like, oh, yeah, before
I got in here-- you replay
things that were happening.
And what else do you do?
You think about people?
Why?
Because we're social
primates, and that's
what we care a lot about.
You don't think
only about people.
Some of you guys might be
trying to solve a math problem
that you couldn't solve before.
But most people in the scan
are asked to do nothing,
are recalling events, which
usually involve people,
or thinking about people, OK?
So this whole suite of brain
regions that was called
the "default-mode network" is
just the regions that are more
engaged when nobody tells you
what to do than for a whole
bunch of things when
they tell you what to do.
And so it's some weird mix of
daydreaming and other stuff.
And the interesting
thing about it
is they're reasonably
systematic.
So those are the--
I keep getting confused here.
Hang on.
Let me get this right.
Did I label this backwards?
All right, they're
the green guys.
Yeah, deactivated
during demanding tasks.
Yeah.
There's too many
negatives for me here.
The green guys here-- does
that look familiar, that patch?
What does that look like kind
of, not exactly but kind of?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Visual,
the visual system.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's sort of
near the visual system, yeah.
It is, but it's also
like something else we've
been talking about recently.
Our TPT.
It's a little further back, but
it's right in the same region,
OK?
And here are these
medial regions.
There's a medial view
of the left hemisphere,
like, "take my right hemisphere
out and look at the inside"
view.
That's this-- [INAUDIBLE]
and sulcus, right?
All these medial regions.
It looks a whole lot like the
social-cognition network that I
talked about last time, that
you identify with the contrast
of belief task versus--
the false-belief test
versus a false-photo test.
So that's weird
finding number one,
that there's a
systematic set of regions
that are engaged at rest.
They're called the
default-mode network
because they're what you
do by default when nobody's
controlling you externally.
So that's finding number one,
and there's finding number two.
But first, Jack, did
you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just wondering,
does deactivated
during demanding
tasks necessarily
imply that it is activated
during not-demanding tasks?
NANCY KANWISHER: We're not
distinguishing between those.
We're just taking
those two conditions.
You'd have to have
some third baseline
to figure out whether
those two were different.
And that's very problematic
because we're are we
having a problem saying, what
counts as a baseline, right?
So we'll just compare
those two, OK?
So that's weird
finding number one.
And it's not that weird when
you think about it further
because, of course,
you're doing stuff
when you're lying there, right?
But the further finding that
really put the default mode
network on the map
was when people
started putting seeds in parts
of that default-mode network
up here and finding that
they got the whole rest
of the network at rest, OK?
So all of those things
are correlated at rest.
It's not just that they're
all activated at rest.
Their time courses are
correlated at rest.
So, actually, what people mean
by default mode network now
is not, I took the reverse
contrast and all the stuff that
activated more for rest than
task, I call that default mode.
Actually, what they mean
is I stuck a seed in there
during my rest scans,
and I took all the stuff
that was correlated
with that position
because those pick out, more
or less, the same thing.
OK?
So that's led to a
whole lot of discussion
about what the default mode
network is, and what it means,
and what we can learn from it.
That's what all this says.
I'm just trying
to figure out how
I'm going to do this because
I'm going to run out of time.
Maybe I won't run out of time.
We'll just go for it.
OK.
So people started messing
around with these correlations
at rest.
And they found
that you could find
other systematic sets of regions
if you stuck seeds elsewhere.
And so another systematic
region, a set of regions,
is all the hot-color ones,
the yellow and red ones here.
And so if you look
in there, you see
various things-- the
interparietal sulcus,
a bunch of frontal regions,
Visual-Motion area, MT,
or other visual
regions down there.
And they found
that set of regions
was strongly correlated
with each other at rest.
You stick a seed in here, and
you get all that yellow stuff,
OK?
And then they looked at it, and
they said, yeah, right, we've
seen those regions engage.
Whenever people do demanding--
potentially demanding tasks--
they've seen that before
in other task contrasts.
So all those things that
turn on when you really
have to pay a lot of
attention and you're
doing a really hard task--
all those regions do that,
and they're also correlated
with each other at rest.
OK?
And so there's this convergence
of these two different lines
of work--
task contrasts
that just say, what
makes a given set of
regions turn on or off,
and correlations-- which
things are correlated at rest?
OK?
And so they're both
converging here with these two
different networks.
OK, so I need to
do a little sidebar
on this other hot-color network,
not the default-mode network
but this other one.
It was originally
called "task-positive"
because it turns on more
when you do tasks than rest.
I mean, that's a really
vague statement, OK?
But it also has
lots of other names,
and the name that we're
going to refer to here
is the multiple-demand
regions, OK?
Multiple demand comes out
from another line of work
that just converged with us.
They're picking out pretty much
the same set of brain regions.
But "multiple demand" means
lots of different kinds
of cognitive demand
activate those same regions.
OK?
So I can give you a difficult
spatial working-memory task.
I can give you a
difficult perceptual
orientation-judgment task,
a difficult arithmetic task.
In each of those cases,
I can compare them
to an easy version
of the same task,
and I'll get, more or
less, those regions there,
which are--
it's getting a
little vague here,
but they're pretty similar to
the task-positive ones, OK?
So this is both
interesting and scandalous.
It's scandalous because-- to
me only, not to anyone else--
because unlike all the regions
we've been talking about so far
that have these very
specific functions--
they just do face recognition
or just theory of mind--
these ones will do anything,
almost, anything difficult, OK?
So whenever you engage
in a difficult task--
I'm skipping over a
whole literature--
it's a big literature on this--
but lots and lots of
totally different kinds
of tasks that have
nothing in common other
than they're very demanding--
you engage those regions.
And in some ways, that's an
even more fascinating puzzle.
Like, what the hell would
those operations be?
What is in common between
spatial working memory
and arithmetic and
line-orientation judgment
and all the other
things that have
been shown to activate these
regions when they're demanding?
Nobody knows.
I think it's a big,
fascinating puzzle.
Someday we'll have a
computational story
about what's actually
computed in those regions,
but we don't yet, OK?
There's a lot of stuff on
the multiple-demand regions,
and they're interesting.
But I can't resist
one little thing.
All right, I can't.
I have no self-control
because I'm not--
I don't have enough
multiple-demand activity
right now, so I'm going to have
to just tell you these things
because they're cool.
OK, so a guy named John
Duncan has spent the last 15
years arguing that the
multiple-demand regions first
are really truly
multiple demand.
He's tested lots and
lots of different tasks,
and they're very,
very domain general.
But second, he thinks
they're implicated
in fluid intelligence.
Fluid intelligence differs
from crystallized intelligence.
Crystallized intelligence is
stuff like your vocabulary,
just stuff you've
learned and cached away,
and facts you've stored, and
abilities you've-- specific
abilities you've stored.
Fluid intelligence
you measure with stuff
like Raven's matrices,
where nothing you know
is going to help you do it.
You just have to be smart
and see some abstract pattern
or something like that.
And so Duncan thinks
that these regions are
related to fluid intelligence.
And one of his measures of
that is if you find people
with brain damage--
he had a big set
of around 80 people
who had brain
damage who he'd been
studying in all different
parts of the brain.
And what he found is if you have
brain damage in those regions,
your IQ goes down as a result
of the damage in proportion
to the amount of cortical
volume destroyed by the damage.
If you have damage
anywhere else in the brain,
your IQ is unaffected.
You may become paralyzed, or
aphasic, or prosopagnosic,
or akinetopsic.
You may have any of these
very specific deficits
according to where it lands,
but it won't affect your IQ.
And so the picture here
is that in addition
to all these special-purpose
processors that this course has
been focusing on, we
have this thing that's
kind of like the brain's
CPU or something like that.
And it seems to live in
approximately those regions,
and it seems to under--
it seems to be essential
for fluid intelligence, OK?
So I'm skipping over
lots of literature
just to heighten that this is
a particularly interesting set
of regions here, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do people
study novelty?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The regions that
specialize in novelty.
NANCY KANWISHER: These guys
will be interested in novelty.
These guys will be interested
in novelty but not only.
You can do the same boring
but difficult task on, and on,
and on, and they'll keep going.
OK.
The reason I went
on that sidebar
is that you can identify
these regions, not just
by scanning people while
they're doing difficult tasks
but by sticking a seed
in any of those regions
and getting the others, OK?
That's the task-positive
network pretty much, OK?
So we're getting
this convergence
between sets of
brain regions that we
find with a task contrast
and sets of brain regions
we find by finding what's
correlated with what.
And the bigger picture
of this whole thing
is that I've been focusing
on individual regions
and what they do, and the
gist of this whole resting
functional-correlation
literature
is a very relevant
level of organization
of the brain is not just an
individual cortical region
but a set of cortical regions
that seem to be in cahoots.
And, again, we don't know
what that means exactly,
but they're correlated at
rest, and they have something
to do with each other, OK?
So we're finding this
higher-level organization,
and the multiple-demand
system is part of it.
OK, so how are we
going to look at this?
So there's a bunch of these.
I've talked only about the
default mode network and--
it's another name for the same
thing-- executive control.
Don't worry about it.
You think of that
as multiple demand.
It doesn't matter.
But there's a bunch of them that
you can find by sticking seeds
in different places.
And so yes, I just
said the big idea here
is that networks are
an interesting level--
an interesting kind
of unit in thinking
about brain
organization-- bigger
than an individual region.
It's a set of regions that
have something in common, OK?
But I've sort of backed into
in this awkward way of saying,
OK, here are things that are
correlated with each other,
and here's what we know
about the same regions
from previous task analysis.
Most of the literature on
resting functional correlation
just looks at correlations and
doesn't try to put it together
with what we know
about those regions,
and that just seems
deeply weird to me.
So for years, I ignored
this whole thing
because it's like,
I don't know what
these resting correlations are.
And if I don't
know what they are,
I'm not going to work on them.
And then Idan Blank came along.
And when he was a first-year
grad student at Fedorenko,
said, hey, we have all these
resting-functional data.
Let's have Idan, for his
rotation, for a month,
analyze the
resting-functional data.
I said, resting
functional-- we don't
know what the hell it means.
Let's not bother.
She's like, get over yourself.
Let's let him play with it.
Well, thank God she's
not as stuck in her ways
as I am because Idan
spent just a month playing
with some of our data, and
what he found blew me away.
So here's what he did.
He said, OK, let's start with
actually identified regions
of brain where we know
something about what they do,
like the language system and
the multiple-demand system.
OK?
Let's identify those
regions in each subject
individually, and then let's
scan subjects at rest, OK?
First, you scan subjects with
sentences versus nonwords.
You find the language regions.
Then you scan them with a
difficult-versus-easy spatial
working-memory task.
You find the
multiple-demand regions.
Then you scan them at rest, and
you get the average timecourse
from each of those
regions at rest.
These are fake data, just
to give you the gist.
Makes sense?
Are you with me now?
Now you can ask, OK,
which of these things
are correlated with
each other at rest?
And this is now a
more interesting thing
to do because we're asking this
principled question of regions
we know something about
rather than random seeds
in some random location, right?
OK, so now what we do is we
examine those correlations.
And we just ask, for
example, how correlated
are those timecourses of two
different language regions
or those two different parts
of the multiple-demand system?
And how strong are
the correlations
between the systems, some little
piece of the language system
and some little piece of
the multiple-demand system?
Makes sense?
So that's a cool question to
ask, and that's what Idan did.
And here's what he found.
Let me first orient you.
So here are lots and lots
of regions of interest
that were identified
functionally-- a whole bunch
of language regions
up here, a whole bunch
of multiple-demand
regions down here.
The details don't matter, OK?
But what I'm going to
show you is in each cell,
we're going to have a
correlation between a given--
so this would be a given part of
the cell over here-- given part
of the multiple demand system.
Sorry, a given part of
the multiple-demand system
and some other part of the
multiple-demand system,
or over here, a cell would
be some part of the language
system and some part of the
multiple-demand system, OK?
So when you do that,
here's what you see.
Here are the correlations
at rest between all
of these pairs of conditions.
And if you squint a
little-- you don't even
have to squint much--
but the black ones
are the ones that are not
significantly correlated
at all.
Blue means a
negative correlation,
and hot colors mean a
positive correlation.
And so what you see is here
are all the language regions.
These are the right-hemisphere
language regions,
which barely even count.
They're just there
for the hell of it.
This is really the
core language regions,
and you can see
they're all correlated
with each other, even ones
that are really far apart--
Broca's area and
Wernicke's area--
10, 12 centimeters apart--
strongly correlated at rest,
OK?
And if you look
at different parts
of the multiple-demand
system, they're
all strongly correlated
at rest, even
regions that are far
apart-- something way
up in the frontal
lobe, something
way back in the parietal lobe--
strongly correlated at rest.
And so yeah.
If you zoom in here--
so what this is really--
does everybody see that this is
revealing a lot of structure?
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So the diagonals would
be, like, self correlation,
right?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
that's why it's black.
Actually, what is it?
Oh, you know what?
It's split in half.
It's actually a
better way to do it.
You take your data, and you
have two different halves
of the data.
And so it gives you
a baseline for the--
no, that doesn't make
any sense, does it?
Never mind.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: It is maroon.
AUDIENCE: If you
look at the spectrum
on the bottom, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER:
All right, I'm going
to have to solve this offline
because I'm now confused,
unless Anya can figure it out
right now and bail us out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, but
as they're pointing out,
it's not black.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I'm saying
it should be high.
I was just wondering
[INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
it's a correlation of 1.
Is that what it is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, because
it's correlated with itself.
All right.
OK.
Thank you.
Anyway, does
everybody get the gist
that all of these
different pieces
of the multiple-demand
system that we identified
individually-- they're all
correlated with each other
at rest?
All these different pieces
of the language system
are correlated with
each other at rest.
And there's no
correlation at all
between any part of
the language system
and any part of the
multiple-demand system at rest.
All of these-- OK,
maybe a couple.
These cells are all either
black for not significant
or inversely correlated.
That's the cool colors.
So do you see how this gives
us a totally cool way aside
from just the
functional localizers we
ran to identify these regions
to show us that these things are
functioning as a system, right?
It's not just that Broca's area
is a cool little thing that
does a piece of language and
some bit of the temporal lobe
is a cool thing that does
some piece of language.
But those guys are part
of a broader system,
and these resting
functional correlations
are revealing this broader
system and the integrity
of the parts within it,
as well as the distinction
between those parts and parts
of another system, or network.
Does everybody get that idea?
Good.
That's a big idea
for this lecture.
I think what I'll do--
so you can--
I'll skip that.
So this is basically
the correlation
between all of the cells
within the language system,
all of the cells within
the multiple-demand system,
and any pair of cells
between systems here.
So that's just averaging over
the matrix I showed you before.
And so this is a cool
way to ask about broader
systems in the brain.
And I was going to show you some
data published just a month ago
that asked this question
not just about the language
and multiple-demand
systems but also,
about the theory-of-mind
network, which is basically
really similar to the
default mode network.
But the theory-of-mind
network we
can identify that we
talked about last time.
And you can go think offline.
Actually, I'll
take a suggestion.
What do you think?
Should the
theory-of-mind network
be correlated with
the language system,
with the multiple-demand
system, both, or neither?
AUDIENCE: Neither.
NANCY KANWISHER: Neither?
Why?
AUDIENCE: This is
something different.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, that's
a totally reasonable answer,
and that's largely
true but not 100% true.
What else might you think?
It is a different system,
and it does function
quite independently
but not perfectly.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
[INAUDIBLE] analyzing
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: All right.
That's a lovely speculation
and an intelligent one,
and it's half true.
I'll just skip to the data.
So in this very recently
published paper,
Alex Paunov, and Idan
Blank, and Ev Fedorenko
looked at the language system,
the theory-of-mind network,
which is not just the TPJ
but these other regions
that I mentioned
briefly that you also
get in the contrast of
the false-belief test
versus the false-photo task and
the multiple-demand network.
Same deal-- identify each of
those regions in each subject
individually, then scan
the subject at rest
and see what's
correlated with what.
And here's the answer.
You see, again, replicate the
language system, especially
in the left hemisphere.
The theory of mind
system is all a system.
And the multiple-demand system
is a system, separate system.
But if you look in
at the cell where
you have theory of
mind and language,
it's slightly above
chance, not theory of mind
in multiple demand but theory
of mind in language, probably
for just the reason you said,
the whole essence of language,
even though it's
a different thing,
than thinking about the contents
of someone else's thoughts.
They are so enmeshed
in each other.
The reason we have language
is to take our thoughts
and put them in your head
and take your thoughts
and put them in our head.
And so it makes sense that
those things are a little bit
correlated.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] language?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah.
But neither of
them is correlated
with multiple-demand.
It's 1:26, so-- or--
wait.
Am I reading the wrong-- yeah--
oh, 12:28.
Sorry.
There's a number here.
That's how long
I've been talking.
So 12:28-- so if you
need to go, that's fine,
but I'm happy to
answer questions.
So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to say,
there was a review paper
about [INAUDIBLE] talked
about how there's a behavioral
connection between theory
of mind and, like, when children
started to learn [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Lots of links,
especially developmentally,
yeah.
Yeah.
Did you have a--
AUDIENCE: By an
extension of that,
[INAUDIBLE] should be
correlated to the theory of mind
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes,
wouldn't you think?
Not really.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: The
FFA is irritating.
It's not strongly
correlated with the things
it ought to be correlated with.